[Musik]
wir machen jetzt heißt es nicht minuten
hilfst du mir heute okay wartet die
schürze ist hier wenn du eine wills
wissen wer macht denn anfangen ich oder
du dich du okay dann begrüßt mal 123
hallo herzlich willkommen zur welt was
machen wir heute dass es da war gut
geraten und zwar machen wir heute einen
cheesecake im käsekuchen aber keine
normalen cheesecake denn wir machen
heute einen san sebastián cheesecake der
san sebastian cheesecake kommt nicht wie
viele denken aus istanbul sondern aus
san sebastian
das ist eine stadt am golf von biskaya
im bergigen baskenland in spanien
die stadt ist bekannt für ihre strände
playa de la concha und blei oder unter
retter und auch für die weltberühmten
restaurants und die innovative küche
das lavina ist ein hübsches restaurant
mit café in der altstadt und da gibt es
nur richtig besondere spezialität den
san sebastian cheesecake und dieser
zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass er außen
fast verbrannt aussieht und im innern
aber noch sehr cremig und fast roh ist
typische käsekuchen haben nämlich
klassischerweise eine goldgelbe farbe
und sind im inneren durch gebacken
womöglich hat vor vielen jahren ein
bäckerlehrling den käsekuchen aus
lediglich fünf zutaten zubereitet und in
welcher weise dann in den falschen
backofen gestellt der kuchen verbrannte
rahmen von außen und war ihnen nicht
durch stadt aber seine fehler
einzugestehen und den kuchen erneut
richtig zupacken ließ der lehrling den
verbrannten käsekuchen abkühlen und
servierte ihn als neue spezialität des
hauses der kuchen kam bei den gästen
sehr gut an und jeder sprach darüber und
seit diesem tag gibt es denn bernd san
sebastian cheesecake zu kaufen und
erzieht jeden tag einheimische und auch
ganz wieder zurückziehen statt
mittlerweile wird der kuchen auch in
vielen anderen städten zubereitet wie
zum beispiel in istanbul wo wir ihn auch
vor einigen jahren schon probieren
durften eine reise nach san sebastian
lohnt sich also auf jeden fall für den
cheesecake braucht ihr nur ein kilo
frischkäse im doppel kam stufe 3 150 g
zucker 40 gramm mehl fünf eier eine
prise salz etwas wandel extrakt und 500
camstar an während er die schlüssel holt
werde ich schon mal die backform
vorbereiten
das wird jetzt gleich ne richtig
flüssige masse daher packe ich jetzt
hier in einem tortenring aber ich muss
den tollen backpapier einschlagen und
jetzt habe ich ein tipp für euch und
zwar nehmt ihr jetzt einen bogen papier
das war jetzt amiras tipp also von
meiner kleinen großen meine tochter
fällt da legst hier drauf den bug ring
habe ich jetzt auf 25 cm durchmesser
eingestellt otto ist echt ne schlüssel
geholt
willst du nicht die glasschüssel oder
bist du deinen namen deine ich habe
gesehen hat sich zuschauer nicht so viel
doch vielleicht eine glasschüssel weil
du bekommst du jetzt auch eine rosa
rührlöffel und dann sieht man den
rosaneri löffel auch okay also kommen
und dann stelle ich sie hier drauf dann
rutscht die schüssel auch nicht okay
wenn du gleich früher stockey kommen wir
zurück zu meinem backform trick das ist
ein trick von samira und zwar nimmt
jetzt einfach einen anderen tortenring
der etwas größer eingestellt ist es zeit
dass hier stellt denn hier drauf und den
hier mit dem backpapier rein und dann
einfach zu ziehen und dann habt ihr
praktisch die innere back form mit
backpapier eingekleidet ohne dass ihr
das außenrum wickeln und hier in den
rand lege ich jetzt noch mit einem back
papierstreifen aus das braucht der
cheesecake auch einfach hier an den rand
legen
und hier oben kann man das einschneiden
umknicken dann bleibt es nämlich auch
schön dran gab backform ist vorbereitet
zumal du kriegst schneebesen dafür
brauchen wir jetzt nämlich gar keine
küchenmaschine ihr nehmt einfach eine
rührschüssel den schneebesen oder einen
kochlöffel und das war's denn der
käsekuchen der so schön cremig seien
nicht luftig daher keine luft
einschlagen und ein sportliches ganze
geschirr und hier ist jetzt nur noch
wichtig dass alle zutaten raumtemperatur
haben also wirklich den frischkäse und
die eier früh genug raus legen
jetzt kannst du schon mal rühren das
geht noch schwierig aber gleich wenn der
zucker dazu kommt geht es einfacher also
gebe ich jetzt noch den zucker dazu den
ganzen jetzt auch mein leopard kleid
anziehen sollen hören und werden im
partner look kreieren sich noch ein
bisschen helfen
nein das kriegst du hin jetzt geben wir
einen nach dem anderen dazu man immer
nur 1 1
jetzt ist schon ein römer schön langsam
hier außen keine luft einschlagen
sondern nur cremig rühren
und jetzt schon lecker hört ja immer
noch das kommt auch noch rein aber komme
[Musik]
den ofen habe ich jetzt auch schon
vorgeheizt und zwar wenig da die
heizstoffe heißluft und wirklich die
heißeste einstellung die wir euch geht
bei mir an dem ofen sind 275 grad 250
reichen aber auch vollkommen aus super
machst du das ganz ganz toll jetzt kommt
man ihr extrakt dazu der uns wenig denn
du weißt es ist hochkonzentriert super
und dann geben wir jetzt noch mehl und
salz dazu das darfst du machen alles
schön klümpchen frank schütz einfach
rein schatz okay dann lieber immer so
war okay eins nach dem anderen
sehr gut mit er noch besser
[Musik]
also eigentlich ist das so ein zur
beratungszeit fünf minuten 3 wir machen
jetzt erst 50 minuten kannst du mal bei
papas minuten mitmachen
murats fünf minuten was macht der papa
immer handy kurzwahl hoppala willst du
die sache rein schütten oder willst du
rühren bis ganz langsam rein schütten
hier für mich schön machen haben macht
mich ja jetzt die sahne noch ein rookie
jetzt schon die masse ist relativ
flüssig aber vorsichtig okay nicht so
große kreise sonst verschütten mir aus
bislang walt gut machst du das
als ich jetzt einfach schauen dass alle
zutaten gut verbunden sind
ihr seht es echt kein hexenwerk einfach
nur cremig verrührt und jetzt wird es
hier rein gefüllt ok einmal finger rein
bereich aber ich kenne kein kennt was
genüsslicher teig nacht als selber jo da
ein bisschen verstreichen und gesagt
kommt jetzt der cheesecake in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei höchster
einstellung ich mache jetzt heißluft 250
grad 2 175 grad ihr könnt auch 250
machen
er muss von außen schön braun werden
ihnen aber noch wabbelig sein ich zeige
euch gleich den kuchen nach dem backen
und dann verkosten wir
[Musik]
nach 25 minuten sieht der kuchen bei mir
jetzt so aus perfekt würde ich sagen
außen oder oben schön dunkel geworden
aber in der mitte noch richtig wacklig
die nehme ich jetzt aus dem ofen heraus
und lasse ihn komplett abkühlen jetzt
dürfte der käsekuchen schön ausführen
den äußeren tod bringen habe ich schon
vor der abfahrt zeit weg wenn wir das am
besten einfach umschlagen es dann zu uns
verletzungen nicht so schlecht dass
außen hier doch noch ein bisschen
dunkler werden dürfen
ich glaube es kann es aber auch daher
dass die back also die wand der backform
ist ihm wichtig war aber so finde ich
gar nicht schlecht
ich glaube wir verkosten beherzt den san
sebastian schief geht
[Musik]
das ist die fotos die ich gesehen habe
von san sebastian also aus dem labinot
die sind sogar noch dunkler also das
wirklich der rand überall dunkle und
hier man sieht schon ella ella wenn die
klappe man sieht sie auch schon die haut
da oben die löst sich und dort ist
wirklich so die oberste schicht die löst
sich freuen also es ist ein kuchen wohin
will ich mal sagen kann im kleber base
verbrannt aber der körper geführt also
erst muss sagen als ich den das erste
mal gepackt habe ich ihn so gebacken man
eigentlich ein schöner käsekuchen
ich würde aus ich würde optisch er den
neben der blauen
aber so ist original kind da ist auch
der probleme machen wir probieren jetzt
genau da muss er ihm drin müsste ja
cremig sehr ähnlich sein
ich habe heute den ofen wirklich
ausgereizt 2 175 grad
okay man merkt es auch 1 mann verschwand
der schwabe richtig wabbelig ja weißt du
was war billig heißt
babbel ich war will das ist natürlich
noch wackelig double bubble habe wir
probieren wird einfach okay wir werden
da klopft sie ganz zeit gehörte tesco am
[Musik]
erinnern sieht man da ist einfach mega
cremig und jetzt wird er einfach so
hingelegt so dort ware sogar noch ein
bisschen dicker ich habe gaben hole ich
muss löffel holen wartet gespannt
wieviel moment slater bin jetzt einfach
von oben nach unten löffel aber sie
kriegen wir die geschmeidig ist ehrlich
sagt laura
richtig cool megatrucks am ammersee will
einfach sagen du passt hab ich mir
stehst nicht durch nicht mehr richten
aber ob ich es sowieso nicht
ihr wisst wie radio gemacht
ich mag es auf wichtigen gern
ausprobieren würde wirklich in so einem
richtigen steinofen bei offenem feuer
war offenem freuen sondern brot offen
aber ich glaube dann so bekommen die das
dort hingegen richtig heiß ein ganz
heißer ofen und dann ist noch wackeliger
ihnen mega also das rezept solltet ihr
unbedingt mal ausprobieren und
cheesecake mit nur sechs zutaten ganz
einfach verrührt ohne küchenmaschine
ich habe nur eine lebendige
waschmaschine dabei gehabt und die immer
schön alle schlüssel mit erledigt die lh
das rezept gibt es in meiner kostenlosen
app und natürlich auch cds - blog.de
macht den kuchen nach probiert hinaus
sorgt ihm eine chance und postet eure
kommentare gern unter das video also bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
das auto da schmeckt ist solche karamell
insbesondere außen richtig karamell ich
so malt sich aromatisch lecker hammer ja
ein foto und dann essen wir den rest
sind macht es nach richtig gut
[Musik]